The
real name of the “Birdman” was Robert
Franklin Stroud. Seattle born Stroud ran away
from home at the age of 13 and was first arrested
in 1909 at the age of 19 after turning himself
in for murder. He shot and killed a bartender,
F. K. Von Dahmer, who had allegedly failed
to pay a prostitute for whom Stroud was pimping
for in Alaska. He was then sentenced to 12
years in a federal prison, though not in Alaska
as it wasn’t yet a state.
Stroud was first sent to serve his sentence
in a federal penitentiary on Puget Sound’s
McNeil Island in Washington, in 1911. He got
into even more trouble in prison where he
assaulted a hospital orderly. He also stabbed
a fellow inmate. (Unlike Burt Lancaster’s
mild mannered portrayal of Stroud in the 1962
Birdman of Alcatraz, Stroud was known to be
an extraordinarily violent, hot tempered man
and by all accounts didn’t change much through
his life in that respect.)
After these two incidents, an additional 6
months was added to his sentence and Stroud
was shipped off to a different federal penitentiary
in Leavenworth, Kansas. It would be here that
he earned the nickname “Birdman”.
He continued to be a difficult inmate to handle
in Leavenworth and frequently threatening
other inmates. In 1916, about half way through
his original sentence, Stroud got in trouble
over a minor incident, and thus, was going
to be denied a visit with his younger brother
who he hadn’t seen in 8 years. Needless
to say, he was furious over this and in a
fit of rage, he stabbed the guard responsible
for reprimanding him and killed him in front
of about eleven hundred inmates in the Mess
hall.
Needless to say, the fact that it was his
second murder and that there were so many
witnesses, Stroud didn’t receive such a
light sentence as the first time- this time
being sentenced to death by hanging. During
this time, he was put in solitary confinement.
However, a series of court battles ensued,
twice involving the Supreme Court, and his
proposed execution was postponed all the way
until 1920. At this point, a handwritten desperate
plea by Stroud’s mother to President Woodrow
Wilson earned Stroud a commuted sentence of
life in prison; but because he was viewed
as such a violent inmate, it was recommended
by the warden that he continue to serve out
that sentence as he had done since killing
the guard, in solitary confinement. This was
instituted and he was put in permanent solitary
confinement.
Over the next 30 years in the Leavenworth
penitentiary, he came to be known as “Birdman”
as he started taking a keen interest in canaries
and other birds after he found an injured
bird in the recreation yard and nursed it
back to health. After that, he started breeding
birds and studying them in his cell, an activity
the guards allowed him as it was a hobby they
thought to be a productive use of his time.
He also earned money by selling the birds
and used it to help support his mother, as
well as to purchase various supplies for himself
to support his bird hobby.
He checked out every book available on the
subject of birds that the prison library offered.
It wasn’t long after this that Stroud became
a genuine world class expert on the subject
(ornithology) and redirected his energies
to writing about them. Having raised hundreds
of birds (mostly canaries) in his cells, studying
their behavior, habitat and physiology, he
managed to author two books titled Diseases
of Canaries and Stroud’s Digest on the Diseases
of Birds, where he even outlined cures for
certain diseases that he himself had discovered.
He was also in regular correspondence with
some of the world’s leading ornithologists.
In fact, he wrote and received so many letters
that the prison had to hire a full time secretary
to read and copy all of them, as it was prison
policy that every piece of mail in or out
had to be read and copied, to make sure there
was nothing illicit about the correspondents
and keep a record of them.
Needless to say, his amazing number of letters
that had to be screened and the filth from
all the birds in his cell resulted in the
prison administration trying to shut down
his business. Thanks to a bird researcher
from Indiana, Della Mae Jones, his story made
newspaper and magazine headlines and the President
even received a 50,000+ signature petition
from people all over requesting that Stroud
be allowed to keep the birds. Thus, rather
than be able to force him to get rid of the
birds, this resulted in the prison administration
begrudgingly giving him a second cell to house
his birds in.
They then switched strategies and simply set
about trying to get him transferred to a different
prison. They were at first unsuccessful, because
when he got wind of this, he married Della
Mae Jones. Why? Because there was a Kansas
state law prohibiting any prisoner married
in Kansas from being transferred.
After several years, the prison administration
was finally able to get him transferred and
his birds and equipment taken away when it
was discovered he was using some of his equipment
to distill alcohol. They then shipped him
off to Alcatraz, where he was given his famous
moniker “The Birdman of Alcatraz”, even
though he was never allowed to keep any birds
while there.
In his 17 years in Alcatraz, still in solitary
confinement, among other things, he studied
law with an aim at securing his release; his
argument being that being kept in solitary
confinement for so long constituted cruel
and unusual punishment. He also wrote two
more manuscripts, an autobiography titled
“Bobbie” and one called “Looking Outward:
A History of the U.S. Prison System from Colonial
Times to the Formation of the Bureau of Prisons“.
In 1959, the famous Birdman of Alcatraz, who
never actually had any birds there, was finally
released from solitary confinement for the
first time since 1916 due to his poor health.
He was ultimately transferred to the Medical
Center for Federal Prisoners in Springfield,
Missouri where he died at the age of 73, having
spent the last 54 years of his life in prison,
of which 42 were in solitary confinement.